نحن هنا في المقلدين في دبي
في مزرعة الجمال الخاصة بي ، أنا في الواقع من ألمانيا
، لم يكن في ذهني أبدًا قراءة
الجمل بالصدفة أينما كنت في
العالم ، الطعام هو النقطة المحورية
لكل ما أفعله ،
اسمي تشينغ  وأنا شيف وكاتب طعام ،
أخذني ذوقي إلى
جميع أنحاء العالم بحثًا عن
نكهات رائعة ووصفات جديدة
أخيرًا أوصلني إلى دبي ولا أطيق الانتظار
لاستكشاف مشهد الطعام الغني والمتنوع
لقمة واحدة  في الوقت
الذي أتيت فيه للقاء طريًا
، أبقى مربي الجمال جميع تقاليد
النكهات الإماراتية على قيد الحياة
عامًا بعد عام منذ الانتقال إلى هنا من
ألمانيا في عام 1988 ما رأيته في ذلك الوقت
وخاصة المدينة هنا على دراجتين
بالفعل كانت جميلة حقًا
تختلف كثيرًا عن بلدين أخريين
لا يمكنك الحصول على مكان أفضل كامرأة
منه هنا ، فالثقافة الماراثية
محترمة للغاية ومنفتحة للغاية أولاً
عندما أتيت كسائح أحببت
البلد الذي أراه أشعر أن هناك شيئًا ما
في الأيام الأولى  قابلت هذا
f  أنا وعائلتي وقعت في حب
العائلة ، لذا فإن الثقافة الإماراتية مليئة
بالحب ، أشعر بانفتاح ما
يمنحه لي أفراد الأسرة ، أعطي الآن للناس من
الخارج عندما أريد أن أقدمها لك ،
شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك
الكثير من الناس.  ليست فرصة لمقابلة
السكان المحليين ومعرفة
تقاليدهم الحقيقية ولهذا السبب أحب أن
أكون مضيفًا والأشخاص الذين
يأتون إلي يجعلونني أذهب وأذهب
[موسيقى]
هذه هي الشاشة الكبيرة
وهو أيضًا في مواعيد امتياز  هذا مثل هذا
الهواء بالنسبة له ، لقد حصل على شاي حلو ، نعم
كثيرًا ، لذا فإن لحومهم حقًا ثمينة ،
أليس كذلك ، إنه أقل كولسترول
في أي نوع من اللحوم وأيضًا منخفض
الدهون جدًا أقل بكثير من عائلات الأبقار الماراثية
إذا لم يكن لديهم  الجمل للسباق أو
للمنافسة لن يبيعوه ،
لكنهم سيحصلون عليه لجميع
أفراد الأسرة
، وأقول أنه يمكنك لمس أنفك كم هي
ناعمة مثل الوسامة ، إنها رائعة ،
نعم ما تعلمته من روسيا هو
أنه يتعلق باستخدام مكونات بسيطة جدًا
ولكن متواضعة  مطبوخ مع ل  لكل
منها تقاليده المختلفة لإعطائك حقًا
ذلك البدوي وهي
تجربته ، لقد كسرت للتو ، نعم ، لا بأس ،
ما هو ساخن أعتقد أنني استأجرت أقدم
ذكرياتي عن الطهي ، إنهم يستخدمون
توابل مختلفة وإعدادات مختلفة ،
أتناول أول ماعز لي  كما هو الحال هنا ، يحتاج الأمر إلى
ساعتين قبل أن تجعل النار جاهزة
والاستعداد بينهما ثم
ساعتين لطهيها ، مما يجعل
[موسيقى] مختلفة
، كانت الماعز رائعة مثل
طقوس بسيطة ولكنها متواضعة تذوقها جيدًا لدرجة أنني أحببت
كل دقيقة منها  لقد شعرنا أن
لحم الإبل
في كمين في هذا المكان هو مجرد ملح بسيط
وفلفل أسود ، وهذا أمر جيد جدًا
لأن الناس كانوا يجلسون في
الصحراء منذ آلاف السنين ،
إنه جميل جدًا
لقد قضيت يومًا سحريًا شكرًا
أنت ملكة الصحراء التي تعرف
أن قلبها هنا في دبي ،
إنها بدوية حقيقية ذات روح متحررة
وتعرف حقًا كيف تقدم الضيافة الإماراتية
[موسيقى]